wir sorgen für mich wie sie dann steht
das richtig so gut ist hallo ich meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zurück zu einer weiteren folge minecraft
ja und jetzt geht einfach mitarbeiter
haben bestimmt wieder dieses schwarzen
striche was soll das denn für schwarze
also ich bestrichen drückt man das ganze
gibt's wieder schwarz bild moment du
musst das irgendwie das hatte ich auch
eine zeit lang musste mal raus gehen
ohne aufzunehmen aus dem kompletten
spiel und dann das ja umstellen oder so
keine eine stück zu mir kann man also
ich zu dir kommen wäre er genau wie
teile dieser folge mich falls die letzte
pass oft haben wir zusammen ein bisschen
fragen beantwortet und so haben an
unseren häusern gebaut
aber ich konnte die okay ich mache
zurzeit so ja klar
spiegel hat sehr wahrscheinlich ja ich
mache zurzeit nichts an meinem haus
naja so hinein offen ich habe mir gesagt
ich brauche ein paar häuser hin mehrere
okay weil ich mir gedacht habe okay luca
mach mal was für die stadt macht mal ein
paar mehrere häuser hier ein zimmer
irgendwann besuchern oder nur aber jetzt
brauche ich einfach wieder holz an
jedoch holz wo bist du denn ich brauche
ein bisschen und spiegel ist ein
bisschen absetzen
damit trägt die aktion ist nicht trägt
der stadt bin so ja ich habe meinen
immer bei euch ein waldgesetz oder so
keine ahnung 200 blog oder so bei
stadtleben ich war noch nie richtig im
krieg drin glaub ich erst gar nicht noch
einmal mit denen aber das war nur so
halb bekommen simon dass ich mit dem so
bisschen gelebt und natürlich haben auch
wieder kommentare von euch unter dem
hashtag unbekannt und ich suche gerade
nach europa länder davon behält sich vor
pessimistisch an so
wie sich auch ruhig liegt die hand
geschrieben darf man über euch kein
fiction streifen nur an also viele der
mega dagegen und so manche findet so
lustig also mir stört mich das gar nicht
bin dass er lustig nächste apothekerin
ich habe jetzt einige läden da war
irgendein mädchen die hat ein schreiben
das mit katy schluss kommt hätte und
dann wollte ihn zu trösten und trägt
ausgegangen ist kann stilvoll stehen
dafür entwickeln wo mein gott ich finde
diese fanfiction so eklig teilweise da
willst du gesagt so ja ich sage
contractor via nackt auf dem bett lag
und alles möglich so richtig abartig ich
mag das irgendwie gar nicht wenn mich so
viele erzählt wird ich weiß natürlich
dass es nicht stimmt und der effekt ist
auch dafür bekannt dass es ein fiction
ist aber ich mag das gar nie richtig
richtig komisch finde ich das also gut
hier simon
das habe ich erst mal alles falsch
gebaut oder ist das ein versuch mal kurz
mal wechsel auf menschen doch mal weg
noch mal schnell schnell oder langsam
ich hab das glaube ich auch drauf hat
mal mit einem ice bogen ja genau das ist
unsere hab ich glaube ich habe ich den
vsv die kiste was ist denn das für eine
schönste bespannt richtig langsam aber
dinge gewöhnt ist weil ich in crystal
bau gewinnen fristlos richtig krass ist
echt krass
robert kummer ich habe den ich hab den
heftig verzaubert eigentlich nachdem man
hier guck dir den männern die man da ich
weiß nicht was dich dann noch drauf
börsenliga bogen einfach ja sagen habe
ich auch gemacht dabei die drei gut ob
man ein christbaum macht nicht so viel
aber mein größter braucht diesen coolen
river verkehrs killer aber eigentlich
das gleiche verzaubert oder ja ungefähr
ach du bist grad vergiftet oder aber ich
hab' ich habe das richtig cool sein
schwert verzaubert teleportieren kann
zu zeigen auch mit diesem ende medaillon
kurier japan heftige attacke magna droht
und dann holt ab ja das kenne ich ganz
ehrlich ich wollte mal was direkt da
muss ich an mathe vier hier gibt es
leckeres nein jetzt noch fleisch nicht
wie man gute nerven
dankeschön ich habe euch selbst noch
sechs oder sieben oder so oha wies damit
geht will ich meine sachen haben grad
gebrannt simon nicht gut jetzt hilfe
immer wie ich das hier weiter bauen kann
eventuell schloss das soll dieses schnee
das durchdachte da ist ein großer platz
aber euch einfach mal so viele häuser in
dem es teil unserer stadt hin und was
teilt es ja dieses redwood dann dieses
plus wird klenks und dieses mal hier was
du hier siehst ja dann nehme ich das mal
bitte hier
das merkmal hier ist unsere
essensausgabe übrigens hatte letztlich
mal hannelore kraft ja ich hab so gesagt
er soll die hannelore kraft wenn wir wie
die politikerin
er schreibt so hannelore mit nur einem
richtigen behindert hannelore erhalte
drückt man hier so einen button
mal schauen ob das funktioniert dass die
erste ausgabe schreibt
dann bricht er noch ein bisschen mehr
schnitzereien hier
wenn da immer jeder was zu essen drin
hat das coole idee eine kleine
essensausgabe soja du siehst jetzt
sicher den style unserer stadt ich weiß
nicht wie ich das hier bauen soll alter
dieb erwürgt oder vorschnell wir wollen
auch so schnell
das ist ein goldener das ist nur weil du
die festung an hass auf das umfangreiche
drauf für sein passiert eigentlich ganz
nah ich bin damit den 10.000 blöcken
paar sekunden weil er auf einem
fischkutter mich vom server geflogen hat
jemand gesagt man darf damit nicht wenn
sie frisst und auf
natürlich ist allerschlimmste ja das ist
okay oder hat sich wehgetan
da weiß ich denke mal die dürfen wir die
königin fragen
ach ja erwartet da muss halt mal handy
holen moment denke ich schon mal eine
frage aus kuba wo die erste ok derzeit
noch eine frage vor von unseren
zuschauern
ich starte schon mal die lsw das mega
oder zero projekt besser die ist echt
ganz gut
eigentlich ich fange man also ich würde
erstmal grob sagen dass hier auf jeden
fall viel viel viel viel durchdachter
ist auf jeden fall in der regel
zusammensetzung und auch mit den städten
et cetera das hat auf jeden fall den
anreiz gebracht dass es krieg geben
geben kann aber auch frieden geschlossen
werden
aber es ist ja auch noch auf jeden fall
nach lachen die wir besser machen können
aber wir sind ja auch das zweite projekt
und wir lernen immer noch dazu wenn sie
ihren plan du du meintest ja irgendwas
mit tadel oder irgendwie so dass es da
was neues gibt das hab ich nur so halb
mitbekommen aber ich denke wenn es immer
wieder was neues gibt dann haben wir
wieder was dazugelernt et cetera pp
deswegen sonst würde ich sagen das
megaprojekt hat das ganze so angefangen
hat alles mit viel besser dass man gar
nicht diese regelung mit den tod und so
bleibt ist ein natürlich die zuschauer
aber ich denke die zuschauer dieses
ganze verstanden und aus unserer
perspektive sehen die wissen dass es
dass man sich dann halt mehr anstrengen
dass es auch besser ist es dann andere
projekte kommen auf den kanälen und so
und das ist schon ganz gut mit dem
ganzen regeln
deswegen würde ich sagen hero zero auch
muskeln besser was ist besser
sie haben bei ihrer eigenen seiten und
spaß machen zb rottbeck her finde ich
echt cool aber wir hatten am anfang ein
bisschen mehr spaß gemacht als mega
projekt mittlerweile als wird alles
sowieso gar als jetzt wieder alles hier
erkundigt haben und so bin ich auch
wieder gespannt was du so was mal wieder
mal wieder bin wieder auf dem für das
neue sind so cool und ja wir haben hier
noch viele fehler gemacht und so und wir
lernen noch dazu kommt das ist könig ubu
bestimmt was wenn fragen
ob wir töten dürfen seitdem das möchte
ich jetzt mal fragen nein das darf ich
nicht fragen gefällt mir das verboten
ja aber ich hab's nicht verboten
bekommen ich glaube es ist jetzt ende
des monats sie in morag sich fragt jetzt
simon warte warte warte ich noch kurz
etwas sagen okay es ist jetzt ende des
monats und bald es wieder königs war und
wie du eventuell weiß habe ich ein sehr
schlechtes verhältnis zu unserer königin
weil die immer so ein bisschen du darfst
dies nicht und du darfst das nicht im
labor bla bla bla und mir wird dann
immer vorgeworfen dass ich diese map
irgendwie verstellt hätte deswegen hab
ich jetzt eine neue geholt und ihr seht
da oben jetzt mal positive neutrale und
negative antworten zu behalten sondern
komischer haken drin zehn klassen jetzt
so dass ihr seht dass sich daran nichts
um stelle und dann fragen wir jetzt
einfach ob wir die um die fragen sollen
die königin soll ich jetzt auf zurück so
und da die königin das heißt simon fragt
ob wir die könige töten sollen de cuba
wo die erstellung möchtest du dich mein
schwert sterben durch unser schwert ich
würde euch unser schwer tag nochmal neue
thomas könig zu bauen möchte ist durch
unsere sich unsere schwerter sterben
richtig abschlachten private aber ich
habe mein handy ausgemacht ich besser
möchtest du ausgestattet werden
irgendwie so und die cam halten gesucht
werde ein probe-abo werden
abgeschlachtet werden
was ich noch mal abgestimmt möchtest du
abgeschlachtet werden vielleicht darauf
gefreut habe okay ich stelle sie kommen
diese anders möchtest du ins gras beißen
es ist kann sein aber sie weiß es selber
nicht genau wie können wir diesen fragen
damit die vielleicht ein bisschen besser
darüber nach dem was ich könnte neutrale
antworten ausmachen so freunde
led-strahler antworten auch an wir
machen müssen wir müssen wir volles
risiko gehen konnte
okay sie kaputt ist kann sein ist
freilich noch einmal anders doch obama
jetzt hat er hat ihr leben bis jetzt
spaß gemacht ausgeschlossen
kein spaß am leben willst du dir
erlösung
auf keinen fall sie möchte weiterleben
wie du möchtest du denn diese komischen
schmerz ertragen wäre es nicht besser
wenn du dich einfach durch töten lässt
ja es wäre aber sehr nett da man sich
sicher ne möchtest du möchtest du dich
in brot an kopf werfen tokio habe
möchtest du dass niemand die ein brot an
den kopf wirft wird jetzt hab ich den
tornados atmen
möchtest du das hier kein brot den kopf
vielleicht reicht einfach planen cop
killer danke sie also chocobo unser
verhältnis ist jetzt ein bisschen so
dies dass ich habe schnee geholt wo die
ganze stadt zu bauen
sie sagt nein blablabla du bist ja immer
so ein bisschen negativ geblieben jetzt
stecken wir auch wieder den arsch aus
was ich auch nicht so toll begrüße aber
du bist jetzt bald abgewählt ab du musst
ewald abdanken weil in ein paar tagen
die neue königswall ist und deswegen
chocobo wer sich einfach sinnvoller wenn
du einfach sterben würdest gleichzeitig
habe letztens eingestellt hatte da
nichts hören stellte die sie möchte
festigt durch uns stärker vielleicht
möchte sie
möchtest du auch einen anderen weg
sterbe eventuell durch lava oder tnt tnt
möchtest du dich tnt sterben chocobo
gewiss auf einer abo soll wir das jetzt
machen wir sind so holen und in einem
käfig reinpacken
ausgemacht ist klar jetzt private reise
gehen soll mit den djs in deinen
verdammten käfig packen
okay was ich mich doch lieber lover
lover überall aber nicht aus kippen
aber von ganz oben so dass sie ganz
langsam runter kommen willst du das cool
ist das dein ernst das ist unser ernst
und willst es ab schlossen die
ausgestattet ist unser erstes denkt
jetzt 68 so herzlich unser ernst jetzt
machen oder nicht
wie sie da steht das richtig so abkochen
diese nicht zur ware bis in die wirklich
sicher eindeutig gold bleibt okay ich
würde sagen kommt was ist ihre letzten
worte an die die mache ich gleich gleich
hat sich ihre letzte wort haben die aber
schon fließt so lange will sich
schneller erholen ich möchte die sich
ganz nicht jetzt sie sich ganz sicher
aber tnt und wollte sind ihre lover hat
die ganz sicher gesagt okay manchmal
macht er ja ich bin dabei aussehen ich
hab' ich bin hatte ich habe auch zwei
jeder auch ein jetzt schon zwei mal
gemerkt
damit niemand ich gebe mir wenn wir da
sind kommentar nicht oder sicherlich
oder irgend sowas gerade was frisch ist
was war kurz aber da drin ist eine kiste
immer in solchen regionen nicht wären
startklar sind gut ausgerüstet so dass
die lava aber bei mir ist der zeit
ein flugzeug das gebot für die lamas weg
hierher
ja aber da ist noch ein bisschen dass er
nicht für jeden ein eimer oder doch dort
hast du noch 1 52 statt den mal ganz
kurz sein kannst ihr habt ja nur ein
dabei kann ich mal hoch mal vorsichtig
nicht nein das tut not tobago ich komm
nicht dran kommt nicht dran sie man
dachte man auch die cia als ob nicht
doch ein bisschen höher die armut nicht
auskennt ist ja ich habe nicht ich bin
behindert was von holz resources voll
cool ist so genannte cold as
wer hier kann man über keine lager
mitnehmen löst sich ein anderer ort
fehlt weil ich ja nur fünf minuten
einfach scheiße
die hölle das alle gehen ja du ich
glaube schon nach hause ich habe kein
flugstopp damit ich ca zu hause werden
du dies das weiße haus passt mir dein
einmal jemand habe ich also im inventar
glaube ich bin auf mich noch heute ein
hühnchen die welt schicken beide einmal
voll machte simone schon total verwirrt
durch das vorhaben das jetzt haben
ja und ich glaube ich vorlauf mich
gleich heft wird mich umbringen dafür
aber egal dafür bringen wir zog obama um
dann habe ich einen könig mehr und
kämpfe mich da nicht umbringen doch
dürfte er dürfte kev mich umbringen man
kann ja auch nicht nur wohl aber nehmen
dann bist du behindert ja warte mal
vielleicht es ist ein schlechtes omen
ich hoffe wenn du dich verläuft haben
ach deswegen konnte ich kein übernehmen
meine tage voll
ich bin wieder zu hause ich brauche
schon mal so ein gerüst auf mach mal ich
finde einfach den ich bin grad
individuelle reingegangen so voller
enthusiasmus und findet die mittels den
der ausgang nicht mehr wirklich
auskennen hessel conny ich kann nicht
sagen ich habe mir den stoff dann komme
ich zu dir oh nein oh nein verdammt oder
lassen das ist oft die table war schon
wie man sagt jetzt nicht den ausgang
findet nicht im ok ich hole mir im
flugzeug statt dann ich bin auf maccabi
tor wo habe ich überhaupt noch welche
man ich habe gar kein zauberstab ich
noch nie so einen spinner habe ich ja
meine zauberstäbe eingestellte suche
einfach eben das nix da es geht es
richtig weit runter um ihn abzuholen
da ist noch eine aber deshalb kann man
jetzt ging es okay es ging es ab lager
schon mal rauskommen zwischen wir
rauskommen
habe ich nicht noch wie heißt das darf
einfach moustafa
dieses will was man zum verzaubern ach
ja ja aber ich finde den ausgang nicht
mehr
ich habe keine elektrik stuff mehr also
ich hab electric aber ich habe keines
darf man wo ist der ausgang der hacke
und zeit läuft uns davon simon nein auf
17 schnell kippen ausgang nicht gefunden
wir nicht das kann ich auch ganz schnell
raus mit der school of teleport ation
oder so in der app den plan
ich hab den plan damit schnell geht
ich nehme mein schoko weg dahin geben
kurz in die hölle weil ich weiß ich weil
ich und das sagte kandidaten schnell ich
bin auf weg junge ich habe extra die
fristen angelassen jona wehrsold
abschnitt nein tut er nicht das ist ja
nur wenn man ganz schnell geradeaus weil
ich weil ich wenn ich in die lava fallen
ja ich hab mit steve armor an und ich
hab mir electric stuff der aber halb
kaputt ist er habe darin münden kizashi
heiraten
- die schreibt katja und elf ja bin ich
fast super tja und jetzt plus 106 und in
einander in der reihenfolge ist die so 6
0 6
so ist die reihenfolge okay ich gehe in
die richtige richtung das schön
es wird auf jeden fall irgendwo hier
seien eine ganze der ganze vorgang mit
der lava dauert ja nicht lange durch die
wände gerade habs glaube ich man gleich
brauchst ein obsidian ab ich hab aber
ein flugzeug stadt gehört ja auch sein
ob sie dann abgeseiht war das portal
kaputt da kann man hier muss auch so
sein und mich doch ich sehe dich ja ja
noch drei sekunden wir machen das schild
jetzt herausgekommen ist ein schoko
komme hier langsam geht am stock
tja da ist die stadt hier ist die stadt
das ist gerissen ja habe ich muss nur
dran setzen
ja und du auch der 2
ok go wo wir machen dieses flugzeug ist
kaputt ich muss eben den stadtrand hier
beides unbedingt cool ich mache das für
sie hier ist doch dass gerrit pfennig er
ist okay geben mir da noch einmal 8 uhr
auf der a 8 uhr auf der noch ein neues
gruber ich mache die linke seite mit
rechten seite ok ok 321 die letzte was
denkst du bist du wieder leben
seitdem ist
womöglich sagt sie
sie war die hre stand doch simon hilfe
was ich verbrenne ich im rennen simon
ich würde sagen leute simon schnell wir
müssen jetzt über zehn jungen arztes wie
im kampf gegen tag dass meine
entscheidung
simon alles gut alles gut alles gut
alles gut
hab den dienst ja ok die quelle ist was
über ob sie die anteile halte aber ich
glaub ich krieg das weg ist alles okay
oh mein gott wir einfach unsere königin
getötet die voltis jahren auf ihren
wunsch gehört zählt war wieder alle nur
zu besuch
simon ist ein kleiner schulter war nur
was sich lohnt zu besuch okay leute beim
hfc irgendwann die tage der neuen könig
haben sollte das alles kein problem wie
so fließt das wasser darum nicht ob ich
hab mal ein wasser eingesetzt
keine ahnung leute werden euch gefallen
hat und ihr was zu lachen hatte dein
freund auf jeden fall
dann will ich sagen das wetter und bis
zum nächsten mal
ich baue dann irgendwann wieder alles ab
da